[Music]
you never came home from proposing he
just disappeared
it seemed kind of awesome though that I
came straight here after Jimmy left me
on that hill and haven't left
okay so we're three months later aiya
what is Gretchen up to when we catch up
with her again Gretchen has not left the
house in a little while I would say
she's more in a manic state than she is
a depressive state okay so she does
crack Boily yeah let's stay here and do
crack so I take it you're not going to
therapy I'm very excited about Lindsey's
journey this year and she's a full-on
assistant stylist she has her sleigh
dashing forward um she owns her own
place she's making her own money she's
not relying on Paul anymore he's in the
past she has a new haircut
so she's the whole new woman and I'm
very excited I mean we've basically done
like a complete role reversal with Jimmy
and Gretchen they were this I guess if
you can say stable ones and so now we've
kind of taken their place for a little
while as they're doing their own little
things yeah I started a really cool
dinosaur mural on your wall being Jimmy
I think he's he's kind of unaware of the
impact of the whole proposal thing and
he has this ridiculous idea that there
is still hope for them at all the time
if she makes it as hard as she should do
who is the worst of season four oh I
think that's Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy but I do
think out of the four of us yeah Jimmy
Jim Jim Jimmy's thing he takes white
fronts in addition I think what what I
did at the end of last season then what
you do halfway through the first block
gets you and I back to the top no I get
a pass I get a pass you let me on top of
the hill after proposing to me yeah and
how did you retaliate exactly spoiler no
spoiler but it's ten times worse than
the than the other thing mushroom cloud
[Music]
you